how y'all doing reject nation gonna
check out a trailer today for another
HBO film Michael B Jordan and Michael
Shannon in the adaptation of Fahrenheit
451 which is a classic sci-fi novel if
I'm not mistaken never read it don't
ever expect me to either have you ever
seen a physical book before do you want
to know what's inside
insanity gosh damn by the time you guys
grow up there won't be one book left
little knowledge is a dangerous thing
news banks memoirs internet world the
world
bürol you're not born equal
so who must be made equal by the fire I
want to burn I really wonder how many
killed longer references people were
thinking of during that last line right
because I haven't read the book my first
impression that I get comparing it to
equilibrium I don't know if you guys
have seen that movie or one of those
dystopian futures where the whole world
has to repress their emotions and I
actually heard one time when I was
talking about equilibrium with someone
that it kind of seems like it was a semi
inspired by something like Fahrenheit
451 burn I want to burn because I
believe in this specific story Michael B
Jordan is he's a fireman who's great at
his job he's involved in all the book
burnings and then one day he meets a
girl who like inspires him to become a
rebel of some sorts kind of like how
equilibrium sort of is I love Michael B
Jordan as an actor I love him as kill
monger mmediately what he's is bird it
immediately my mind also goes hey Black
Panther and Rudy said to bird and stuff
I mean I love this concept it's
interesting to know that this is based
on a book where the book is about the
future where they burn books and I think
in a day and age we're getting a lot
more sci-fi than we used to yours
images here that have kind of like that
neon type of lighting that you might
have seen like Blade Runner 20 or 49
ghost in the shell' or even Netflix is
mute it doesn't seem overblown with that
there's some really cool shots you do
get in here like the images of like
Michael Shannon's face like the
television kind of being projected onto
the side of buildings but overall it
actually looks like a rather contained
sci-fi thriller and everything that kind
of rises at equilibrium to is the way
they're dressed the kind of all black
leather costumes that all the characters
have Michael Shannon is the main
supporting character who seems like he's
probably gonna be the main antagonist is
no surprise Michael Shannon seems to fit
well into the antagonistic role
interesting seeing how he's been doing
some television work lately I know he's
just in Waco and I was in this it's just
cool seeing that Michael B Jordan just
is coming off the heels of playing Eric
he'll monger where a lot of people
hailed him as
one of the best MC you villains possibly
the best now he's starring in another
film that is sci-fi and you one could
argue Black Panther definitely has a lot
of sci-fi to it where he's actually the
main character he's the hero of the
story it seems I'm looking forward to
most are just the dramatic sequences
between Michael B Jordan and Michael
Shannon because those two Michael's
going toe-to-toe those intense actors
could make for some really great scene
work I really appreciate this trio
because it doesn't really show you a
whole lot of the movie it's more giving
you just the tone the style some imagery
kind of the tone that I'm getting from
it is more along the lines of a de Neve
a new type of approach or even like a
David Lynch esque type of approach and
the music in the trio was really cool
too I'm hoping that they stick to this
kind of music for the actual movie
itself it seems like an HBO movie that
I'm more than excited to check out I
kind of wish it was all going on the big
screen because this looks like a big
screen type of movie but who knows we're
actually doing it on HBO you get a lot
more creative freedom you might get a
really cool movie out of it I don't know
how accurate it's gonna be sci-fi books
being adapted or known to sway from the
actual source material but as long as it
keeps its main themes you probably keep
fans of the book happy and honestly if
in the future they decided to burn books
that would take a lot of pressure off of
me what was feeling pressure to read
books I don't want to read I feel like I
could be smarter but why try this is
America subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and go check out our patreon full
length TV show of music video reactions
over there would love to see you over
there with weekly Q&A as well
you